نتائج الايام الاولى من الهجوم المضاده
على روسيا تزامنت معها موجات تفاؤل تصدرت
التصريحات الاوكرانيه اذا حتى الساعه
استطاع الهجوم المضاد استعاده سبع قرى
شرقا وجنوب اوكرانيا وابرزها بلهودانتي
نسكوتشي
التقدم الذي اعلنته كاف يمنح نحو خمسه
كيلومترات فقط للقوات الاوكرانيه التي لا
يزال امامها نحو 90 كيلومترا للوصول الى
ساحل بحر ازوف وقطع الجسر البري الروسي
الى شبه جزيره القرم الجيش الاوكراني
بدوره اكد ان قوته تتقدم باتجاه مدينه
الشرقيه البلاد كخطوه لاستعاده بقيه
الاراضي في نفس الوقت اقرت كيف بخسائر
فادحه في العتاد بعد ان اخرج كمين الروسي
رتلا من مدرعات برادلي الامريكيه ودبابه
من العمليات فيما عرف بمقبره الدبابات هذا
وتؤكد موسكو ان الهجوم الاوكراني الم ضاد
فشل وتم احباطه ولم ينجح في اختراق خطوط
الدفاع الروسيه نتيجه جاهزيه الجيش
[موسيقى]